the best way  the only way  we can  honor  the death of helena hutchins is to find  out the truth any suggestion that we're  not complying myself and any lawyers i'm  working with or what have you is a lie i  have no worries about that i have no  worries about that that's all gonna work  itself out  regardless of what they say in these  right-wing rack sheets and  people who are all about hate  um but setting aside all the  the hate  setting aside all the january 6th of it  all  there it is  what  why did he hold up a packet of splendid  what so he held up a packet of splenda  in which he had drawn a smiley face  oh okay uh well  i guess he's innocent